so it's been basically two weeks since I
pulled my sim for my tennis max and made
the SN plus my main device in an attempt
to see how much greenery of the grass is
on the other side and let me tell you it
definitely is in a lot of ways but it's
patchy I'm working on my full detailed
review of the s10 plus from an iPhone
users perspective so make sure to
subscribe and enable notifications so
you don't miss out but for now here are
the biggest things that stuck out so far
first off face ID is amazing and yet I
already knew that before but switching
over to the SN plus I could tell that
this is definitely much easier to use
and it's more convenient the ultrasonic
sensor is very cool and it's also very
secure which you'd know if you watched
our fingerprint hack video but it really
is a hidden miss and I did add my
thumbprint additional times which did
help but I also tried to learn it how
much pressure how fast but it still
misses quite often and I have to redo it
multiple times which is quite
frustrating face ID is effortless fairly
quick and works in apps without needing
to do anything now above the ultrasonic
sensor is the best smartphone display
I've ever put my eyes on definitely more
detailed in a tie ready and watching
movies with it is fantastic especially
in HDR now the iPhone isn't bad by any
means but you do notice a difference
switching back to it especially if
you're streaming 1440p with a samsung
along with that the dual speakers are
really loud after a lot of use I don't
think they sound as good as the iPhones
but I would take that as a trade-off
because when you're in a loud
environment or you're watching a video
that's fairly quiet it's nice to have
the extra volume the battery powering
this gorgeous display is over 25% larger
than the one in my tennis max but
doesn't help in the real world honestly
I'm not too sure both of them lasts a
full day of heavy use but are close to
dead when I go to plug them in at night
so I'll take a closer look at this for
my full detailed review one thing I had
to change are the icon packs since they
are very cartoony in my opinion I also
hated the way the stock keyboard worked
and I swapped it out for the Swift
keyboard
I remember hearing the Apple went
through a ton of keyboard iterations
before Steve was happy and this really
shows we're using the iPhone the
keyboard just works great in general you
have a ton of customizations and options
with sn+ but it does take more effort
and overall I'm happy with how my iPhone
works and it kind of just gets out of
the way one thing I'm not happy about
are the features that are completely
excluded in iOS versions of apps that I
saw in multiple different ones the
biggest one probably being YouTube's
picture-in-picture mode which is so
helpful if you're multitasking
I both love and hate the notifications
on one end the sn+ an Android provide
much greater looking notifications with
more info like thumbnails for YouTube
videos if you chromecast content you get
constant controls in the notifications
and one thing I love is having that
constant notification bar where I can
see if I get new emails and texts before
I deal with them it's really helpful if
you're doing something when you get a
notification to not just forget later
with a quick glance I could see if I'm
in silent mode if my alarm is on and a
bunch of other icons and notifications
along with that I like the always-on
display and I really wish Apple would
implement this now that their high-end
flagships have olla displays along with
these notification differences we also
get a lot more annoying ones that I
wasn't used to with iOS system
notifications downloads and just plain
ads for apps I didn't download like
Spotify Amazon is suggesting products I
should buy modern combat needs
reinforcements and asphalt 9 just
refueled my car you could definitely
disable and adjust notifications for
apps but these are just things I didn't
have to deal with before now let's talk
about the cameras I absolutely love the
wide-angle lens and even though I don't
use it that often when you're in a
situation where you can use it it's
really great to have you can also get
some really cool perspectives the
Samsung photos have more contrast and
saturation than iPhones which is great
if you don't like to edit one big
difference between the two is the
portrait mode being wide compared to
telephoto and there are pluses to both
so I really wish that both of these
companies would give us the option to
use either one whichever fits the need
samsung has made major strides in terms
of image quality especially if you look
at just the note 9 those released half a
year ago and the photo quality is
basically comparable don't lay down site
about the s tens camera is the shutter
lag well it does mean the images have
less noise I often found myself missing
shots on my kids because it actually
takes a little bit time from the time
that you press the shutter button until
the phone is actually taken where the
iPhone is basically instant the iPhone
feels like a powerful phone for
minimalists it just works yes you have
much less customizations and features
much fewer options when you're taking
photos and everything is much cleaner at
the expense of notifications but it just
works and is less frustrating if you own
other Apple products the iPhone is an
even better device with continuity
airplay
airdrop etc this has been the case for
years but what hasn't always been the
case was the hardware quality both with
materials and feel and other things like
camera and sound quality the iPhone used
to be ahead in many ways but with the
Galaxy S 10 series I feel like this is
the first time I could say that the
hardware is actually better overall
thank you guys for watching my two-week
real-world comparison between the
devices if you have any questions go
ahead and ask in the comment section
below and I'll try to cover them in my
full detailed review of the galaxy s 10
plus if you want to see that make sure
to hit that subscribe button right over
there
this man max max tech and I'll see you
in the next video